former President George HW Bush is in a
Houston hospital this morning one week
after the death of his wife the family
spokesman says the 93 year old
contracted an infection that spread to
his blood but is responding to
treatments and appears to be recovering
last night First Lady Melania Trump
tweeted quote sending healing thoughts
of strength along with prayers for
President George HW Bush tonight David
beg no is outside Houston Methodist
Hospital David good morning good morning
there's a report out that the former
president is in the intensive care unit
but a bush spokesman will not confirm
that report mr. Bush was admitted to the
Houston Hospital
just 24 hours after his wife was buried
seated right in front of his wife's
casket on Friday former President George
HW Bush shook the hands of mourners who
came to pay their respects
one day after Barbara Bush's funeral
Bush 41 was admitted to the hospital
with an infection that spread to his
blood blood infections are very serious
particularly elderly CBS News medical
contributor dr. David agus said the
whole process of grieving can be
stressful on the body which can
compromise the immune system you couple
that with sitting in a ceremony where
you're shaking lots of hands greeting
lots of people hugging them kissing them
the potential for spread of infection is
real mr. Bush has a form of Parkinson's
disease
the 93 year old has been hospitalized
several times in recent years including
for two weeks last April with pneumonia
and chronic bronchitis I think dad got
sick on purpose so that he could be with
her that's my theory at least at Barbara
Bush's funeral on Saturday her son Jeb
described how his parents were
inseparable even recently being admitted
to the hospital at the same time the
bushes were married for 73 years longer
than any other president and first lady
in US history
Jeb Bush says in his mother's final days
he asked her how she felt about dying
and she told him this I don't want to
leave your dad but I know I'll be in a
beautiful place
a family spokesman says the former
president has made it clear he wants to
get out of the hospital and get to his
family's home in Maine to spend the
summer there the former president has an
adventurous spirit you might recall he
went skydiving at 80 85 and 90 and he
will turn 94 in June he is by the way
the longest living US president David
thanks that house in Kennebunkport so
central to the Bush family want to get
there I would imagine right away and
he's always rallied you know this he's
we've seen him down he's always rallied
but he always had Barbara by his side
too it was so touching to see him there
in front of her casket greeting
everybody let's hope that he rallies
again he's been in and out many times
and he was always run out and you're
right get well soon mr. president